[Music]
so we had a visitation in the solar
system a little while ago by um
did i pronounce it right abby
very well yeah
now was that an alien civilization
exploring or was it just the lumper
space rock that happened to be passing
through uh the gravitational field of
our solar system abby i know you have
opinions on this
uh yeah well i have a book that came out
a few months ago
this object didn't look like any comet
or asteroid that we have seen before it
was the first object from outside the
solar system that we spotted near earth
and it was
flat in its shape based on the analysis
of the reflected sunlight
uh it was pushed away from the sun by
some excess force that declined
inversely with distant squad
and there was no cometary tail coming
off it there was no gas around it so
i simply suggested that maybe it's a
very thin object like a sail being
pushed by reflecting sunlight and there
was such an object that we produced a
rocket booster that was discovered in
september 2020 called 2020 so just to
demonstrate the concept
at any event i wanted to highlight the
fact that you know
as jocelyn mentioned over the past 70
years we've been searching for radio
signals
and that is uh just like trying to speak
on the phone with a counterpart and you
need the counterpart to be alive
and in my view most chances are the that
most of the civilizations technological
civilizations that existed are dead by
now they had a short window of
opportunity where we could have
communicated with them but they are not
around and so the best method to find
evidence for them is to look for relics
that they left behind equipment they
sent into space and the discovery of a
muammar is a wake-up call and of course
the best way to figure out whether an
object is artificial or natural you know
it's just like when you go on the beach
you know you see most of the time rocks
that are naturally produced but every
now and then you see a plastic bottle
and so what you want to do is if you get
an alert of an object as where this
was you want to send a spacecraft with a
camera that will intercept its
trajectory and take a close-up photo
and you know they say a picture is worth
a thousand words
in my case a picture is worth 66 000
words the number of words in my book i
wouldn't need to write the book if we
had a close-up photograph now easter
have commissioned something called the
comet interceptor
um which i'm super duper excited about
because um it's going to be launched
before it knows where it's going um and
then when a comet or something useful
comes in then it can and set off to to
make a trajectory so would that type of
instrument work for for your your goal
to take a photograph of an
extraterrestrial passing through our
solar system
yes uh definitely but and there was the
osiris-rex that's another mission
uh that actually landed on the asteroid
bennu not long ago and took a sample
from it took a photograph and a sample
it looked like a rock and it will bring
back the sample to earth in 2023 so just
imagine us landing on an artificial
piece of equipment
reading off the label made on planet x
and importing the technology to earth
you know it could represent something in
our future if the experience would be
just like
getting access to a cell phone
long before it's offered to the public
and enjoying all the features that it
gives you now justin you described this
sort of
trying to sort of search for things have
been set out a bit a little bit like a
needle in a haystack what were your
opinions or what have you saying here uh
i believe there's been a second visitor
from uh another solar system
i think omomoa has had a successor
one that we haven't seen nearly as well
and we don't have pictures of it but uh
an object came by i think in 2020 and
not 2019 yeah
yeah yep um and its trajectory means it
must have come from another solar system
so
that's the nearest we've got to kind of
direct contact and it's and it's pretty
indirect but it's interesting that we're
now in a position to be able to pick up
some of these visitors from other solar
systems
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv